In this extreme HDR selfie photo, both the
Pixel 3a and XS Max seem a little bit underexposed,
and the OnePlus 7 Pro is the only one that
gets the white balance spot on, but it doesn’t
have as much detail as the S10+, so I’m
giving this one to the Samsung.
In this one, the Pixel 3a has some pretty
harsh shadows, and the S10+ looks to be a
bit too cool on the white balance.
The XS Max looks really detailed in this photo,
but due to the clouds being so blown out,
this one’s going to the OnePlus 7 Pro.
Moving to the rear side, both the 7 Pro and
XS Max look a bit dull and flat, and while
the S10+ looks very detailed, it’s looking
a bit dark and lacking highlights.
The Pixel 3a looked the closest to real life.
And if we crop in, we can easily see that
the S10+ has the most detail out of these
phones.
In this portrait photo, we see that same detail
shining on the Samsung, with the Pixel 3a
right behind it.
However, the Pixel’s white balance is way
too cool.
You can see that the S10+ uses the regular
lens instead of the telephoto lens for portraits.
The OnePlus looks a bit blurry or lacking
detail, and the XS Max gives us a nice balanced
photo.
We see the same exact thing in this photo
so it may be due to noise reduction or a low
shutter speed.
The Pixel 3a is way too blue, once again,
and the S10+ is really smoothing out the detail
in the face.
We’ll go for the XS Max again for this one.
We also noticed that you can’t adjust the
blur on the OnePlus 7 Pro, and the XS Max
blurs out the T-shirt, which looks a bit weird
but is actually realistic.
No here’s a very tough HDR photo.
The S10+ does the best at keeping the details
in the sky, and we actually notice a lot of
detail in the hills and trees in the background,
and that’s because it has dual apertures,
so it’s shooting at F2.4 instead of around
F1.7 with the others, and the XS Max has some
very distracting lens flare going on.
If we take a closer look, the Pixel 3a actually
does the best job at properly exposing and
keeping this young lad.
In this photo, the S10+ overexposes by a good
amount, making the sweater look faded, just
like the OnePlus 7 Pro looks, without exposing.
It just looks a bit dull.
The Pixel 3a looks the best overall with great
detail and colors.
In this portrait blur photo, the onePlus 7
Pro actually does the best at edge detection,
with the other phones struggling with a few
areas here and there.
In this macro shot, the flowers were blowing
in the wind, so the phones had to freeze the
motion to get good detail, and the Pixel 3a
did this the best.
Although the XS Max doesn’t look as detailed
because of the lack of contrast, I really
liked how it exposed the image.
This photo was shot at maximum zoom, and we
can see that the Pixel 3a can’t zoom in
that far since it’s the only one that has
a single rear camera, and because of that,
you lose a lot of detail.
The XS Max did pretty well but it’s lacking
contrast, and the S10+ is the clear winner
in terms of detail, although the colors are
oversaturated.
In this macro shot, we tested minimal focus
distance and the S10+ was able to get the
closet, and it’s the most detailed as well,
with the Pixel 3a right behind it.
Part of this tree was in direct sunlight,
so it was interesting to see how each phone
dealt with it.
The XS Max was really flat, and the 7 Pro
and Pixel 3a crushed the detail in the shadows.
The S10+ again has the most detailed camera.
Two of these photos are shot using an ultrawide
lens, with the 7 Pro and the S10+, and it’s
interesting to see how saturated the s10+
makes this photo, but it still looks great
compared to the rest.
One thing I also noticed was that the OnePlus
7 Pro’s ultrawide camera really lacks detail
compared to the S10+.
It’s a night and day difference.
You can see here that details are smeared
and the sky in completely blown out.
The S10+ does an excellent job at this and
you can see a lot of blue in the sky.
Switching to the regular lenses, the Pixel
3a actually looks the most detailed here,
followed by the XS Max.
For some reason, the 7 pro and S10+ looked
a bit faded, with the least amount of detail
on the 7 pro.
This is another tough HDR scene, and we can
see that the Pixel 3a blew out a lot of clouds
and underexposed the grass.
The XS Max chose to expose the scene very
well but blow out all of the cloud detail.
The 7 Pro does a decent job but the sky looks
grey, almost like they brought the highlights
down more than they needed to.
The S10+ definitely wins here.
And here’s the ultrawide versions of these
photos, showing that same difference in ultrawide
camera detail.
In this one, it was up to each phone to freeze
the motion of the spinning the tire to capture
a detailed image, and the Pixel 3a again did
the best at it, shooting at a higher shutter
speed, making for a great looking image.
And we tested the same thing here, with the
Pixel 3a giving a very detailed image, followed
by the XS Max, then the S10+, and the very
blurry looking OnePlus 7 Pro.
This photo was shot testing shutter lag, hitting
the shutter button as soon as little Elon
got to the closest point to the camera.
The XS Max features zero shutter lag, so it
was basically instant, followed by the S10+,
then the OnePlus 7 Pro, and the Pixel 3a,
which takes quite a while to snap a photo
after you hit the shutter button.
This one was shot in the shade with a bright
sky and lake in the background.
The XS Max was really dark, and while the
S10+ looked really good, his face is really
orange here due to oversaturation.
The OnePlus 7 Pro lacked quite a bit of detail,
and the Pixel 3a did the best overall.
In this photo, the S10+ looked way more detailed
compared to the rest, and the sand was actually
exposed very nicely at the same time, so I’m
giving it to the S10+.
However, in this sunset cast shot, it’s
oversaturated and the water looks way too
green.
The OnePlus lacked detail, and the XS Max
was a bit too cool, so this one goes to the
Pixel 3a for looking the most true to life.
This scene was very tough since the sandy
beach is completely in the shade, with direct
sunlight hitting the buildings in the background.
The S10+ oversaturates quite a bit, and the
building on the 7 Pro is a bit blown out.
The XS Max looks great, but it’s lacking
some contrast, so this goes to the Pixel 3a.
Zooming in 3 times, we see the same results
here, except that the Pixel 3a loses detail
since it lacks a telephoto lens, giving the
win to the XS Max.
Now at maximum zoom, the Pixel 3a looks very
pasty, and the S10+ is oversharpening a lot
of the details.
The XS Max looks detailed, but there’s a
lot of noise, especially in the clouds, so
this one goes to the OnePlus 7 Pro.
Here’s another one at maximum zoom.
The XS Max again has a bunch of noise, and
the Pixel 3a just looks terrible.
Although the S10+ looks to be more detailed,
if we crop in, we can see that it’s due
to oversharpening.
The OnePlus 7 Pro actually has more detail.
It’s just lacking some contrast.
In this food photo, the S10+ looks really
good, but it just oversaturates the colors,
leading me to choose the Pixel 3a despite
the cooler white balance.
Here’s a dark indoor photo with some bright
details in the background.
If you look at the texture on the couch, you’ll
see that the 7 Pro and S10+ are adding a ton
of noise reduction, smoothing out the details.
The Pixel 3a looks great, but it’s way too
cool in terms of white balance, with the XS
Max being very accurate to what it actually
looked like.
Finally, we took a night time photo using
Night sight on every phone except for the
XS Max, which doesn’t have one.
Although the Pixel 3a oversaturated the colors
a bit, it still looked the best overall, being
able to properly expose the shadows and highlights
without introducing much noise at all.
The 7 Pro did a pretty good job as well, but
it was a bit too dark.